all right so for that 28 of people in
wyoming who wanted liz cheney to win i
got good news for you janie is pondering
a 2024 bid this is amazing it's been
like not it was not even a day when she
was comparing herself to abraham lincoln
and basically announced she was running
for president
i couldn't believe it was 20 minutes it
was 20 minutes 20 minutes she was like
the first thing she says
abraham lincoln lost many battles before
going on to win the most important he's
like lost election in the senate and
congress before going on to win the most
important it's like
bro are you calling yourself like are
you comparing yourself to abraham
lincoln yeah and he's saying you're
going to run for president there's going
to have to be a book deal there's going
to have to be some you know tv spots and
special interviews and things like that
tucker nailed it because he was like
she's gonna she's gonna start a
foundation and write a book called like
democracy or something oh gosh yeah
yeah i know and i will paraphrase
lincoln a little bit here and say that
by liz cheney losing by 40 points our
nation has gained a new birth of freedom
away from neocon war mongers yeah for
sure and so points man
but it just goes to show i think that
the point to be made here is that people
always like to say what she did was
brave when she came out and opposed
trump that that was somehow a brave
thing to do the least brave thing any
human being in washington dc can do
yeah the least brave thing any human
being in washington dc can do is claim
to be a republican and come out against
trump you will get showered with praise
from the media you will get you know
huge money you'll you'll if you're like
alyssa farah you'll get a you'll get
your own show you'll be picked for the
view
it's the easiest thing to do ever and so
she's not brave for what she's doing
she's really bitter that donald trump
turned the gop base against her family
dynasty and she was raised with
delusions of grandeur that she'd one day
be president and that's not possible
anymore she's better about it just like
hillary clinton in that respect but i
think a lot of it is that trump insulted
her dad
that's yeah i mean trump was the one of
the like the first major republican
candidate for president who came out
called out bush and cheney for the iraq
war that was amazing that was the only
that's the only reason liz cheney hates
him has nothing to do with january 6. it
was a convenient way for her to become a
martyr for her father's political legacy
what it all has to do is that trump
basically destroyed her family dynasty
and she'll never be president because of
it so we talked about how you know what
i think four is it four of the ten who
voted for impeachment republicans who
voted for impeachment retired yep maybe
more
yeah
yeah retired there's more there's eight
there's only no no no no eight are out
two one but uh i think yeah i i might be
more than that because i think two uh uh
lost
now how many lost so i'm yeah i'm trying
to think um
jamie herrera butler just lost to joe
kent so that's one yes
um
but it's it's a picture of entire books
he did everything the democrats wanted
him to do and they thanked him by
gerrymandering
imagine being as cocked as adam
kinzinger oh what a loser
that guy is is like such spineless
establishment trash defending ray epps
it's like are you joking dude you could
come up with a better excuse well he
didn't actually go in the building shut
up you're better off saying nothing that
guy has no spine and so it's it's all so
much more sweet knowing that they
basically just booted him out so if
if the january 6 committee continues
into the next congress
they're not going to have any concern
any republicans on the committee at all
well it's not it's not it's not going to
continue
to kill it it's not going to continue
when republicans win the house because
they now have the power to make
committees and suspend committees so
they would be able to just turn it off i
don't trust the republicans but i am i i
do think we're getting a lot of those
maga republicans in so maybe we'll see
something we are we are we've picked up
a lot of w's in these primaries like
i've i say to people all the time
primaries at this point are more
important than general elections
because like you can elect a republican
but if it's somebody who's going to be a
squish and not represent you the way you
should be what's the point but we've had
a lot of wins in this primary a lot of
great people have won who will actually
fight for the people who elected them
jack besobic nailed it the other day
when he said that the january 6 hearings
are like a true crime show for all the
wine moms you know to watch and they're
getting ready for the next season or
whatever and he's right i mean they put
it on primetime tv
it's it is probably that demographic
who's listening to this going like oh
wow and you know the funny thing is as
much as they claim to hate donald trump
a lot of these people are the ones who
are probably writing him love letters
once he goes to prison assuming like
these are the kind of people that write
love letters to serial killers
so evil but i love you so much oh they
they secretly love donald trump because
donald trump is what gives them ratings
donald trump is what gives them page
views like i mean the ladies
oh yeah that's true i'm saying like
there are women who write love letters
to serial killers and like how they they
want to be with them and it's like that
dude like straight up killed a bunch of
people but they love it so like i'm
saying
these these these true crime women that
are watching january 6 are you know
actually you know let me tell you this
there's a viral video of someone asking
three women what is a woman
or like or i'm sorry it's it's a it's a
young woman asking three other women and
someone had a good point about it i'm
not sure who it was it might have been
matt walsh and he said
they all know exactly what a woman is
but they're trying to reconcile what
they know it is with what they're
supposed to say right and so so that's
that's basically the point i'm getting
at people
will
say they hate trump say it's also evil
but they're so excited watching this
hearing about this dangerous
large donald trump they're probably
getting all lusty but how do you even
like enjoy that like i watched it for i
watched the first one for about 10
minutes and i felt like i was at a party
and some guy i hate came up to me and
started talking to me about his 401k and
excruciating detail that's what i was
like who who can cite through this it's
just you're listening to adam kinzinger
and benny thompson just drone on for
hours on end but they're eating they're
sitting there eating popcorn they're
like oh what's going to happen next
it's it's it's you know they made that
podcast muller she wrote i think that's
what it was called during the russia
gate mueller she wrote
and it's it's just that it's like true
crime conspiracy nonsense for suburban
wine moms i guess that's liz cheney's
constituency
for president
i mean probably
yeah
i mean like i just gave him that season
they loved it what's hilarious about
that to me is the fact that the media
and the democrats newfound fondness for
the cheneys it's hilarious and it goes
to show there's there is a uniparty in
dc and they all secretly want the same
things and that's why they love liz
cheney so much it's not because she
spoke out against trump it's because
they all agree at the end of the day
it's not just that they all agree they
want to maintain their power structure
and they don't want anybody to come in
who's going to disrupt that that's true
so that's why they that's why they stick
together
but she's just like not a good person
either like
one of my favorite stories ever in the
history of politics is in 2014 she tried
to primary mike enzi senator from
wyoming keep in mind liz cheney in her
formative years only lived in wyoming
for two years she grew up in suburban
virginia she went to mclean high school
this is like 10 minutes from where i
live which is hilarious and she's
running for senate wyoming and when she
announced it was a facebook post that
was geotagged to mclean virginia
and then in this race she came out and
publicly denounced her sister because
her sister is a lesbian and she came out
and publicly denounced her right right
right right right right right right
right right right right that was
recently that this was 2014. oh wow and
so like no matter she denounced her
sister for being gay so she came out
against gay marriage and she has a
lesbian but yeah she did that and no
matter what your views on gay marriage
are if you're somebody who would come
out and denounce your own family in
order to win
a political in order to communicate
like that is just that's literally like
that's not just not not somebody who's a
good person and like somehow she found
her way as chair of the republican
conference when she made it to the house
take a look at this this is uh
liz cheney donate to the great task
is that a picture of abe lincoln it's a
picture of abe lincoln this is gross
what's their obsession with i understand
it's the party of lincoln and all that
but like the lincoln project they're
like abraham lincoln
donald trump what it's all this it's the
same stuff as like remaking game of
thrones and remaking the lord of the
rings and they're remaking abe lincoln
trying cultural stagnation they're just
trying to stick with a brand that they
think works well like her whole her
whole reelection like she never had a
shot of winning like not in a million
years like this whole thing was just a
giant grift to raise money for an
eventual presidential campaign that will
also be a giant grift and that's now
she's obviously she's doing that and
that's it right there because i was
saying the other day like why wouldn't
she just retire and try and save as much
face as possible like all these other
guys and then i and now i realize like
she she she probably spent very little
she probably raised much as she could
she went around saying democrats you've
got to support me we got to stop trump
collecting all this money and then she
probably didn't spend it she's probably
just like i don't need to use i'm going
to lose anyway but i can keep it for
something else which is hilarious
because she raised big money like from
left wing like nine and like ninety
percent of it came from outside wyoming
which is
i just absolutely love the democrat
twitter personalities who are like the
republican party died today and it's
like dude you don't you don't like her
and you're not in you're not part of it
anyway like you have no idea but but
it's just like
that
we expect that they wanted the party to
survive and do well no you hate
republicans you rag on them all day
every day you're only you're only
supporting her because she hates trump
if given the choice it's like kenzinger
he he he drops to his knees for the
democrats and then they're like
excellent and then they just they can
slap them kick him into a bucket and
yeah and that's what it's like actually
like a movie villain where the you know
the villains always just like kill their
own henchmen yes and there's a lesson to
be had here if you're a republican like
i just thought of another impeachment
republican that just got primaried peter
meyer from michigan who just lost to
john gibbs peter meyer in his primary he
you know he voted to impeach trump he
voted for gun control he voted for
ukraine aid he voted for all these
things that are incredibly unpopular
with the republican base
and what did the democrats do to thank
him they spent thousands of dollars
boosting his opponent in his own primary
and he ended up losing it and it just
goes to like if you are really going if
you you will never appease these people
you know who will never ever appease you
does not matter you know who made the
right choice
jeff van drew that's true yeah when the
impeachment stuff was going on he was
like i'm not doing this and then he
switched and then he won he was
primarily a landslide
it was like 80 80 points or whatever
he's he's a he was a former democrats a
moderate guy in south jersey
backed trump and ended up winning the
primary landslide yeah amazing and like
people said i remember my mom was pissed
about that she's in she lives in jersey
what she doesn't like jeff andrew yeah
she didn't that makes no sense no
you see
this is the problem with american
politics and i'm not trying to be mean
to your mom but if you would vote for a
democrat
and then one thing changes i don't think
we should impeach trump so i'm i'm off
the democrat party and you're like well
now i don't like him like huh thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there is a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there